you kind of have a role in this of
making a better 2025 you have such a big
megaphone is there something you think
you can do on this podcast that could
create a better 2025. I think if
anything
I could help in leading by example
but you know that's only going to help
the people that are listening I don't
know uh what else I can do in terms of
like make the world a better place other
than express my
hopes and wishes for that and just try
to be as nice as I can to people as
often as I can but I also think that
I've fallen into this weird category
particularly with the Spotify deal where
um you know I'm one of them now I'm not
a regular person anymore now I'm like
some famous rich guy